rien de tel qu'une bonne choucroute pour
maintenir le moral des troupes la
première petite fête des cheminots du
mans à leur dixième jour de grève
motivée est terminé pour eux pas
question de céder je suis agent de
conduite depuis 1970 ce conduit et ran
marchandises express autorails
ça fait 25 ans qu'on dit merci du
confluent vous le voyez comment
ça si je pouvais le savoir
on côté des cheminots pour ces petites
soirées leur enfant leur femme
est gentil sauvagine fuyant titulaire et
il faut faire avec
et en litres
à l'extérieur près des rails le piquet
de grève tous ces insultes de près les
discussions les réunions à paris mais la
plupart affirment ne plus avoir
tellement confiance
on nous dit c'est toi qui t'y de changer
dans des limites à m'expliquer pourquoi
on a trouvé 100 milliards da ce qui
porte à 10 d'où il vient c'est un
journal c'est bien aussi qu'il est
condamné c'est bien l'argent des
contribuables quand même non alors
comment dieu des gens que je respecte
les gens de l'état qu'il dirige dont on
a pu qu'être en revanche c'est fini le
ton est ferme la choucroute été bonnes
dans toutes les têtes la perspective
d'une grève qui va durer